competition is like right around the  corner and in order to level the playing  field we've all agreed that we're gonna  dance the same dance we're gonna do the  cha-cha we're gonna dance to the same  song the only thing we have to do is  come up with our own choreography we got  to have a WoW moment and you know had  some success with the cha-cha in the  past but you didn't hear that for me  here's what I'm thinking if we're just  doing that little cha-cha thing that's  not gonna win right so we gotta like  Peppa duck we definitely have to add to  it yeah what about that little spinning  thing that you do what do you mean  remember that thing that you do you do  anything and you come spin into me and I  dip you remember mm-hmm uh-huh  you spin yeah oh and then you look at  something over yonder and that's not  taking again and I do this and I go what  are you gonna go today yeah I think it's  just uh it's just like but we gotta like  intimidate them yeah